[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always
my name is caleb denby and i will be
your driver
on this journey i hope you all had a
great memorial day weekend
uh because i had an especially great
memorial day weekend as you have
probably
already read in the title i actually
took first place in my section at the
chicago open this year
i was in the under 2300 just barely
snuck in there with my 2200 rating
um and won all my games believe it or
not i took a half point by in the first
round and went 6-0
for the remainder of the tournament so
tonight i wanted to take you through
some of my games show you how it all
went down
what it takes to win the under 2300
section
at the chicago open not the open section
i think there was some confusion in the
chat
i'm not that good i promise the winner
of the open section this year was
actually
st louis local darius swirtz so
good day to be from st louis without
further ado though let's
jump into the games here and i want to
show you first uh my round one game
against evan huang so
evan had the black pieces in this game
and i didn't really do any prep going in
uh i just you know my philosophy for
tournaments
is pretty much always just play what
you're used to
and uh play what you know don't do
anything too crazy
because you'll find yourself uh you know
losing a lot of time in the opening if
you're less familiar with
it you have to think a lot more and it
can end up backfiring but let's jump
into
how this game went against evan so i
play my normal d4
evan ended up doing knight f6 i go c4
g6 knight c3 bishop g7
and e4 so we're in the king's indian
defense
evan goes d6 bishop b2
castles and now i play knight f3 so
uh with this move i am entering just the
classical orthodox variation of the
king's indian defense
so what that means is black now has
really about
five different options for how he wants
the game to go
by far the most popular is playing uh
e5 here challenging the center directly
and
we'll see how the game can continue
after that but black does actually have
a few other options here you can play
bishop g4
you can develop this knight first you
can even go for an early c5
but by far the most popular is e5 and
that's what my opponent plays in this
game
i end up castling and now my opponent
can choose between knight c6
knight a6 knight d7 or even takes on
d4 just all different lines to choose
from but my opponent again
picks the main line with knight c6 so
now
uh after the game i had a quick chat
with my opponent
and apparently this is uh one of his
first ever games
in the classical kings indian he doesn't
normally play
this line but he wanted to try out
something new for this game
so that turns out to have been not such
a great idea for my opponent
and i'll explain why in a little bit uh
i go d5 my opponent plays 97
i go 91 my opponent plays knight d7
all the normal moves i go bishop e3
and then these strange knight moves make
a lot more sense when you realize
black's plan is to play f5 expand
on the king's side and try to checkmate
white in the meantime
white's plan is to expand on the queen
side with moves like b4 and c5
and try to open things up on this side
of the board before
black ends up checkmating so black's
mysterious night move is to play
f5 white's strange knight move is to
play f3
supporting the center and giving this
bishop a place to hide when f4
does come on the board so i come back to
f2
and black plays g5 and now i kind of
zoomed through all of those opening
moves we're on move 13 now
and the reason why i went so quickly is
this is by far
well not super by far but this is one of
the main main lines of the king's indian
defense and it's pretty linear there's
not much variation in these lines
this is generally always how these games
go in in this variation
so up to this point that means that both
myself and my opponent were playing very
very quickly
uh just blitzing out the moves because
we had both had this line memorized
and that's perfectly fine but then i
think the mistake my opponent runs into
here
is he kept matching my pace when in
reality
you know i knew a few more moves in this
line but i don't think my opponent
actually quite had it memorized he was
just uh sort of following my pace
and uh you know matching the flow of the
game and that's actually a huge
psychological over-the-board trick that
uh
you can make use of you know there's
sort of different
schools of thought on what you should do
when you know the opening really well
should you just blitz it out or should
you maybe i don't know like feign like
you're thinking like you're not sure
what to do
and i definitely think it's in your best
interest
to blitz it out if you are absolutely
certain about the opening theory you
have it all memorized you feel very very
comfortable
then i really do like blitzing it out
because
more often than not uh your opponents
tend to match your your pace match your
energy
and that's what happened here i think so
uh the line that i play
in this case is with rook c1 and that is
technically the most popular move
but knight d3 b4 a4
even g4 and knight b5 these are all
other moves in this variation so this is
really the first
like massive branch uh to know
if you're gonna play the king's indian
now do you have to memorize a line
against each of these moves
probably not but you should at least be
aware that all of these moves exist
so what this means is this is generally
when players should start to slow
down with the black pieces there's like
seven different moves here
there's no way you have everything
memorized
and so it makes sense to slow down a
little bit make sure you're playing the
absolute best moves
and if you don't do that then what
happens in the game might happen to you
so i play rook c1
pretty much immediately because i know
it's the line that i play it's the best
move in my opinion
and then my opponent blitzes out h5
which is actually not so
strong it's still a playable move it's
been played at high levels before
but it doesn't make the most sense with
black's plan
so who in the chat knows why h5
is just a little bit suspect why is h5 a
little bit wrong
it's a pretty deep idea and if you're
not very very familiar with the opening
it's not going to be easy to understand
why this move is
a little bit incorrect
so what do you think chats king zlatan
says
h5 is bad i kind of agree i don't think
it's as awful as you might expect but i
don't think it's very good
and jf says it exposes the king so
that's actually not it i'll be impressed
if anyone in the chat can give me
the the reason i'm uh thinking of here
so
h5 continued to weaken the king side so
that's not really going to be it at all
h5 is entirely thematic with black's
plan
black wants to play h5g4 g3 and
checkmate the white king and h5 is
definitely helpful for that plan
as black in this variation you have so
much space
on the king side that you you really are
just pushing
h5 g4 in many many games and winning the
game on this side of the board
um in this case though there are
slightly more useful moves black could
be playing
and we're gonna see that impact uh as a
result of
the next move that gets played so knight
g6 is a much better move
for black or rook f7 uh alternatively
rook f6 is like
super different rook f6 is the line that
black plays when black wants to play for
checkmate immediately
but knight g6 and rook f7 i think are
both pretty similar moves
and they both have the same idea what
idea is that
well the idea is with rook c1 white has
very much telegraphed uh the plan
white wants to play c5 take go knight b5
and start to gang up on the c7 pawn or
the c7 square
so with knight g6 what black is doing is
essentially preparing for this idea
by uh getting ready to bring the rook up
to f7 where it can both
defend the seventh rank and prepare to
swing over to the g-file to help
influence the attack now this is a very
nuanced idea
as to why h7h5 shouldn't be played just
yet
but it is you know not irrelevant right
every tempo matters in the king's indian
and
already getting my opponent to blitz out
a move like h5 i think is a pretty big
concession by black so
these rook f7 knight g6 moves i think
are a bit better than h5 it's not like
black is losing yet
but again a little bit of a concession
there so how should i respond
to age five knowing that it's a little
bit of a mistake
how should i respond
and yeah king zlatan has the right idea
we just go c5 anyways
and as the king is saying in the chat
you get a slightly improved version
because black just isn't quite ready
with these defensive or offensive ideas
with the pieces coming over to the
king's side so i played c5 pretty
quickly i was reasonably comfortable
you know and knew that this was the the
correct move more or less
and then my opponent immediately blitzes
out
knight f6 and this move is just awful
this move is just very very bad
so uh am i saying you should
never try new openings that you aren't
fully comfortable with in tournaments
not necessarily if you're you know if
you're not expecting to like win the
tournament or anything
and you want to get more comfortable
with new openings
uh trying them out can be a great thing
to do just know that you're
you're taking a pretty substantial risk
uh
also when you do try out a new opening
it is
very very important not to do what uh
evan did here which
is just blitz out moves assuming you
know what's going on even if you
actually aren't entirely short because
there's no bluffing in chess um okay
maybe there's some bluffing in chess
but bluffs rarely work in chess so
pretending you know what's going on
isn't the same thing as knowing what's
going on and in this case
knight f6 is actually just a losing move
it's like plus two already for white
you simply take on d6 continue with
knight b5 just
the thematic idea and then knight c7
is very difficult to stop in fact the
only move that stops it
is knight back to e8 and this move is
bad
for obvious reasons being
you move the knight many many times but
the easiest comparison i can make is
rather than playing knight d7 to f6 to
98
black alternatively sometimes just plays
98 in one move
so black is essentially down two tempe
on
on an actual line here and that's just
very very bad
in the game what my opponent did was
even worse um
at this point he he did take a little
bit of time but he
very confidently played the move knight
g6 and this
is just giving up giving up on the game
unfortunately
um and after knight c7 this rook is
essentially dead if you play rook b8
bishop a7
and this rook is entirely trapped no
place for this work to go so my opponent
plays g4
i take the rook he plays g3 and
uh for the rest of the game he tried
some kind of attack on the king's side
but it's just not meant to be i just
take the free pawn
drop my bishop back bishop h6 rook c2
knight h5
and then it's a little bit of a moot
point because pretty much everything is
winning here
for white but i'd like you guys to come
up with a nice defensive resource
in this position i'm happy with the move
that i found i think
it really just ends the game on the spot
more or less so wait to move and secure
the victory
obviously we're up a rook so there's
more than one way to go about it
but believe me when i say that i have
lost better positions in the king's
indian not over the board but
uh definitely online i've lost positions
up more material for less of an attack
so what can we do here to completely
nullify this kingside attack
someone in the chat is asking my
favorite question caleb denby won the
chicago open
yes uh not the open section but the
under 2300 section i did win
it's my new favorite question i walk
around waiting for people to ask me how
my weekend was
and then i tell them
so deep in says g3 deep and shoe says g3
so
not quite the right idea there but i
like where your head's at
i do i like where your head's at how did
you come up with g3 g3 is just not good
you lose a pawn you get checkmated but
the correct move is in fact a pawn break
in the form of
f4 now what makes f4 different than g3
well the point is that now all of our
pieces have access
to the king's side and it's going to be
very very easy to defend the king
now that our pieces can get in uh
conversely let's say i had played some
move like capturing this free pawn
all of a sudden things can get a little
bit tricky on the
king's side for example knight g to f4
let's say i just save this piece or
something
you know it's not a lot but uh you can
tell how
you know a mistake might be made like
let's say obviously like a piece is
hanging but let's say in some position i
played like king h1
uh this is already going to be like
at worst a draw for black with stuff
like this coming in
and some kind of attack on the king
right
so it's clear that's um while i am
entirely winning it's not completely
without risk like it's pretty good for
white
it's honestly almost entirely without
risk but f4 is a nice move just to lock
everything down and make sure that this
this attack never gets off the ground
uh my opponent actually blunders again
here with naiji iii i think you have to
try taking this pawn and although it's
not going to get you very far
but he played knight g3 and now bishop
g4 is simply a winning idea this bishop
is
essentially trapped on c8 my opponent
tried taking f4
but now i simply take g3 take c8
take f8 play bishop h3 and
my opponent resigned i think after
playing the move king e7 so
that was round one uh not such a
difficult
uh game for me because i had a lot more
opening knowledge than my opponent
but the big takeaway here is actually
from my opponent's play
like it's great to know your opening you
know if you get lucky you know the
opening a lot better than your opponent
and you get an easy game like this
but the the takeaway is that when you
don't know the opening
you should be spending your time just
because you are in the opening stage
doesn't mean you can't make game ending
mistakes and that's what happened here
uh evan unfortunately kind of lost this
game before he ever started playing it
just cause you know he didn't think like
if he had thought
and still missed uh these ideas then
that would be one thing
but he never even really gave himself
the chance so that's the lesson to take
away from this one
alright up next i want to take you to
round two
against benjamin tang so
let me tell you about benjamin tang now
i had one
thing that i wanted going into this
tournament and that was to not play any
children
uh because most of you probably know
we've had a bit of a global pandemic
going on
for the past little while now um and
that means
there's all these kids who haven't
played chess
for a year and their brains have just
been sitting in their head
growing developing and they're horribly
horribly underrated
so of course in round two they pair me
with a 10 year old
so here i am against 10 year old
benjamin
tang now benjamin i think is rated about
1950 uscf
but unfortunately for me he's rated
about 1400 feet a
so i had a lot to lose in this game
against benjamin tang and this actually
ended up being one of the most difficult
games of the tournament so
remember the name benjamin tang because
i think in a few years you're gonna see
him at
events like the u.s juniors i would be
surprised if you didn't
but okay benjamin plays e4 we get the
kero khan
he goes knight d2 i take the main
variation
and i go bishop f5 i'm not one of these
crazy knight f6 guys i just go bishop f5
and then my opponent stuns me with the
move knight to c5
so many of you might not be as familiar
with this variation it's very much a
sideline
and black is thought to be able to
equalize really in any number of ways
uh b6 is a very common idea just to kick
the knight away
knight d7 is also very common um i play
the third most popular move which is e5
now let me tell you a quick aside here
my opponent in the game started to reach
for his d4 pawn which was very strange
to me
i think he thought that my e5 pawn was
hanging and he was gonna like
capture it obviously this hangs a piece
so that wouldn't be so good
um but as he neared his d-pawn he
violently like threw his hand away
and then shook his head so i guess he
recovered from uh
from almost blundering a piece in the
opening and i really wish he would have
blundered that piece because this game
ended up being quite difficult
instead he found the correct move knight
takes b7 i i think he actually knew the
correct move
just had sort of a moment and you know
he's he's 10 years old i guess he's
allowed to have some moments
um i went queen b6 goes back to c5 the
knight is trapped otherwise that's the
point of my opening so far
and this move is thought to be pretty
good for white but i choose this move
instead
uh just e takes d4 pressuring this
knight again so there's no time to take
on d4
white jumps back to b3 and now bishop b4
check is a very common idea but i
actually just played c5
directly in this game the idea of bishop
b4 check
generally after bishop d2 is you play c5
eventually anyways maybe knight f6 first
but c5 is still coming but i just went
c5 immediately
my opponent shows bishop d3 which is the
main move
i take and my opponent plays queen takes
again very quickly so
uh i believe queen takes is actually a
little bit of a positional
i wouldn't go as far as to say mistake
but definitely a positional
so believe it or not here i believe c
takes is actually going to be
a much better move much more testing
move for
white and the reason for that is
entirely structural
so with queen d3 it's true that you
activate the queen
and you still have good control over the
light squares but with c takes d3 you
are giving yourself this nice target to
look at
on the c5 square and you are even
further strengthening your control over
the c4 square so i think c takes might
have been good
yet another reason why you should slow
down in the opening
just because it's the opening doesn't
mean you're not making important
decisions
so queen takes d3 uh played instead i go
knight f6
and we develop our pieces and castle our
kings like true professionals
and then my opponent plays knight bd2
just heading for c4
and this is a perfectly reasonable idea
i continue developing
we see knight c4 and drop the queen back
to c7
and my opponent plays this move a3
so unfortunately i've put myself in a
very awkward situation here
and that situation is the position is
more or less entirely equal
uh but my opponent is 700 points lower
rated than me
according to fidei and unfortunately
he's
probably that not that much weaker than
me in actual playing strength
um so i had to find some way to
have something to play for here so i
can't you know i can't just put all my
rooks on the e file trade all the pieces
and agree to a draw
because i'm going to lose infinite
rating points so
uh what should we do to try and find
something to play for in this position
as black
how can we do it
do i always play the carol con um these
days pretty much yes
way back in the day i used to play the
petrov but
that doesn't happen as as often or
really
at all these days
and yet jonathan trans making an
appearance in the chat
youtube celebrity jonathan strantz
popping in to say wow
at my big victory appreciate it
so just a spoiler to anyone in the chat
room thinking about using an
engine for this one all of the moves
you're thinking of
are fine they're pretty much all
equivalent this is one of those
positions
where you can play pretty much anything
and you're not going to impact
the evaluation of the position too too
much
uh but i just want to see if the chat
can come up with any
long-term ideas
hello free the robots hello hello
so i like what mike is saying as well as
king
of zlatan so definitely what we need to
do
is somehow pressure these queen side
pawns right we're not going to make any
inroads
on the entirely symmetrical king side
we're not really going to be able to
invade on the e-file our opponent has
just as much control over that file as
we do
so we need some way in the long run to
make something happen on the queen side
this was my thinking as well
so as far as actual ways to make that
happen well
of course this night has to go because
this knight is single-handedly defending
pretty much every square on the king's
side that matters
and i thought that maybe i shouldn't
allow white to get this set up with
b3 and a4 i thought that would be a
little bit too solid
so king's laton mentioned knight d7 to
b6 as an idea to try to remove this
knight fortunately i think that's going
to be a little bit slow
and in the long run you know white's
going to be able to
plant this other knight onto c4 as well
so i didn't see any immediate way to
really shake these pieces loose
but i thought in the long run it might
be nice to have my pawn up here on
a4 so that any eventual end games or
even in the middle games
b3 is going to be a lot less easy to
play
for white and if i ever get this pawn
down the board then
i'm doing a nice job of ganging up on b2
here
so i play the move a5 and i think this
move is fine any other move you guys
were suggesting
also perfectly fine put the rook on the
e file
put the knight on d5 play h6
you know put the rook on the b file okay
oh
i inspected the element on google chrome
should never do that putting the work on
the b file also also fine all these
moves
totally fine but i think that black
should definitely be focused on playing
against the queen side pawns
so that's how i came up with the move a5
my opponent plays this move rookie one
taking control of the file
now just because i'm playing for the
queen side it doesn't mean i want to
completely abandon the e file
so i did play rook e8 just
matching my opponent on this file my
opponent develops with bishop g5
and here you could argue that i should
have kept the tension on the king's side
a little bit more maybe
take this opportunity to play a4 but i
just played the move knight d5
uh simplifying some things we get bishop
takes e7
and rather than take with the rook i
actually chose to take with the knight
here the idea being again i just want to
keep some pieces on the board and maybe
this knight can reroute
to do some nasty things on the king's
side
my opponent plays rook e5 and
i have a question for you chatroom do
you have a tactic
with knight f4 is knight f4 a good move
here
and what do you think white would play
in response
so these are the types types of
questions that you have to ask yourself
during an actual game it's one thing to
spot a move
in a tactics puzzle it's another thing
to spot a move
and try to determine for yourself if
it's actually worth playing
two different things entirely
so given white's last move what do we
think white's
plan is against knight f4 so yeah
king's laton again has the right idea
knight f4 i'm pretty confident
that white was banking on this move
queen e4 getting ready to double on the
e file potentially triple on the e file
so how to continue
knight four loses to queen d2 i'm not so
sure it loses it's pretty difficult to
play a losing move in this position
actually there's a lot of moves you can
play that
don't lose can you explain why knight f4
would be a tactic in the first place so
when i say tactic
uh what i really mean is a set of
forcing moves
right it might not necessarily win
material immediately it might give you
some small positional gain maybe but um
not it's a set of forcing moves it's
something you can calculate
so not necessarily a tactic but forcing
moves
um
yeah so this is the idea i was kicking
around in my head
if you play knight f4 and your opponent
goes queen e4
and all of a sudden you can go knight g6
and this is the series of forcing moves
i was looking at to
uh to try and calculate because now this
rook has to go over here and if the rook
has to go over here
you know you're not a very happy camper
because all of a sudden you're losing
control over the e-file your queen's
opposite
this rook you don't really have any kind
of winning attack
and black might be taking over the game
so at first blush it looks like knight
f4
might just be a great idea but in the
end i decided not to play it and part of
the reason why
was because of this knight d2 idea maybe
even queen f1
black's or even queen b3 white just
simply doesn't have to play queen e4
so something to uh to look at there just
because a move is forcing and you see
one line that's good for you
doesn't mean you necessarily should go
for it now i don't think queen d2
by any means wins the game because of
course this pawn is defended twice and
we can simply move
the knight back to uh to g6 again and
here our opponent is probably just going
to move the brook
but just wanted to highlight that uh all
these games all tournament games are
gonna be full
of these tiny little decisions that can
very drastically change the
the outcome of the game so be on the
lookout for these things in your games
and make sure you you're thinking all
the way through
you know just because you see one line
that kind of looks tricky doesn't mean
you should necessarily go for it
so the move i actually played in the
game because again opponents rated 1400
feet a
um i played rook e to d8 so keeping
pieces on the board
still and maybe now i'm thinking about
uh bringing this knight
to f4 now that my rook is not going to
be traded
if i play this knight to g6 for example
my opponent plays the move g3 stopping
any ideas of knight f4 kind of forever
so after this i take back over my e5
square with knight g6
get rookie four and i put this queen
opposite these pieces
on b7 my opponent plays rook a to e1
i go knight f6 it's time to you know
start kicking these rooks around can't
let them stay there forever
my opponent plays rook back to e2 and
now i continue through with a4
um so you know i've kind of got my
positional space
advantage on the queen side right and
i'm
reasonably happy about that but again
it's nothing too special
in the meantime my opponent isn't
exactly out of constructive things to do
white has entirely taken over the e file
and the next step is to find an invasion
square
so at the moment my knights are doing a
great job of covering all the invasion
squares
so what do you think white does to make
a square
for their rooks and keep in mind
when you're thinking of yourself as the
player with white pieces
remember you're 10 years old you at the
in the meantime
are trying to think about you know
whether or not you're going to get a
juice box after the game
you have to remember how to tie your
shoes um you don't know how to sign your
name yet
so just keep in mind you're dealing with
all of this and also trying to come up
with a chess move
and yeah you guys are entirely right
here uh white should play this
knight f e5 of course the c knight is
too important to move so we move
the the f knight um
now again there's a saying in chess
where you should never
be the one to break the tension because
whenever you capture something
very often you draw your opponent's
pieces into the game
and i think that's the case here so
rather than capture i left the knight's
intention
and actually played this move rook a to
b8
correctly noticing that after knight a5
we are not losing the game to some
knight c6 tactic because we can simply
take on e5 first hitting our opponent's
queen
and rook if our opponent were to capture
we capture back
and i think we are actually winning in
that line so rook 8
and my opponent understanding that he's
1400 feet a
uh captures on g6 so i take back
and rook e7 rook d7
no reason to let this rook stay on the
seventh rank
and we actually get a trade and i take
back with the knight
and i don't take back with the queen
here even though this may look slightly
tempting
because after rook e5 i really can't be
getting away with queen h3
my opponent's simply gonna kick me out
with queen f1 and i haven't made any
progress
so instead i take back with the knight
the reason being
again king zlatan's idea from so long
ago
we need to kick this knight off of c4 to
make
inroads on the queen's side it's really
the only winning idea i could find
in the position for black uh in the
meantime though our opponent is not just
sitting back letting us do it
uh benjamin played queen e4 i go queen
a6
and he just steps back to queen d3
repeating the position
of course i'm not so interested in a
draw so we finally get our move
knight to b6 you know we had our little
scuffle over the e file
and now i get to go knight b6 kicking
the knight away
unfortunately for me benjamin i think
had thought of this and played this move
knight to e5 so what do you think here
chad what should black play keeping in
mind again
we are trying to win the game
trying very hard to win the game in fact
what should we do in response to knight
e5 this is
the tough decision i was faced with in
the game
mike thinks i'm implying that we
shouldn't take on d3
i don't know i don't know
snj says queen a5 okay
charles says queen a5 everybody says
queen a5
so the correct move here is queen takes
d3
so why is the correct move queen takes
d3 because
you shouldn't try to overpress in your
chess games
now that being said uh sometimes i'm
wrong
so i didn't take on d3
in the game but it turns out every other
move leaves black
pretty significantly worse and that is
often how lower rated players
end up winning against uh their higher
rated counterparts they have the benefit
of being able to play simply you know
rely on
the the threat of a draw to force their
opponent to make concessions
and the reason why they do it is because
it works
so in this case queen takes d3 is really
not going to give you anything besides
a draw we can see knight takes d3 for
example
if i go knight c4 trying to break in
this is not going to get us very far at
all i'm not going to get us very far at
all for example rip d1 here
take take take take and
good luck winning this position uh
against anybody
honestly like literally anybody good
luck winning this position so
queen takes d3 pretty much kills the
game i can play like rook
c8 here and try to keep some things in
tension but it's gonna be very very
difficult to win the game
uh after this particular queen trade so
i played the move queen c8 trying to
play on uh the problem with queen a5 i
think by the way
is that after something like rookie four
uh you have to be very very careful what
you do
because uh well first of all this is a
fork and second of all
there are some pretty scary threats
coming your way for example knight takes
f7
actually does leave white with a better
position in this case
so got to be pretty careful about what
you're doing here
um i played queen c8 though and what i
expected to happen
was my opponent was going to play queen
b5 i was going to play knight d5
they were going to take a4 i was going
to take b2
and that was going to be slightly worse
but who can tell me
what i missed when i played queen c8
what did i miss
the problem with c4 there is that i
think the knight comes to b4
chess pro and then rook d1 and your
d-pawn
is weak
good question though should i mention
that
so what did i miss here what's white's
big idea
thank you caesar thank you for the
congrats
all right we've got a lot of games to
get to so no time left to think
um go ahead and pause now if you want to
try to figure it out but of course queen
b5
is actually the the correct move to
start with the big trick i played on you
guys
is that white isn't actually necessarily
taking this pawn on a4
because queen c4 is actually a much
nastier idea
now this knight is attacked this pawn is
attacked it's actually impossible to
defend both of them
so i'd have to bail out with some queen
b7 move
go rook c8 lose this pawn rick takes d2
but here of course white is just
significantly better um
black is only playing for a draw you
know perhaps even simplest is
white uh just taking this pawn off the
board at the first available opportunity
and i'm gonna be suffering in this game
uh fortunately for me though uh my
opponent didn't see it
and this is another psychological thing
that you guys can work on
in your games one of the toughest thing
to do and this is actually something
that happens even at the highest levels
of chess
is switch your mindset in the game so
pretty clearly my opponent's mindset in
this game was
i'm looking to draw this guy this this
old man
i'm playing i'm looking to draw him so i
can get back to my goldfish crackers
and watching spongebob um and so it's
tough to switch from that mindset to the
mindset of oh
maybe i can win this game so because i
think my opponent was in the wrong
mindset he was still just trying to draw
i think he wasn't entirely looking for
opportunities to sort of turn the tables
so that's something to be vigilant for
because even at the top level
um people do struggle with this
switching mindsets so my opponent
instead played queen f3
still attacking f7 but just not in the
correct way
i did actually see this one and i played
queen e6 which is perfectly fine now
my opponent goes queen c6 trying to
trade the queens
um i tried to trick my opponent with
rook to e8 hoping for queen take c5 when
knight d7
while being slightly complicated is in
fact winning a piece
and black should be better instead
though my clever 10 year old opponent
plays
queen b5 so not falling for the trick
and now i must defend my c
pawn so i go rook c8 we get knight d3
and now white is actually making some
very real threats to my back rank
so i had to trade the queens after all
so
why spend so much time on those moves
where you know i missed this queen b5
idea played queen c8
uh and then ended up here so why spend
so much time there well
if you notice if i had just traded
the queens way back here rather than
playing queen c8 if i just taken here
it's almost an identical position right
my rook was on c8 i think in the actual
or c6 in the actual game and in fact i
would rather have my rook on b8
than c6 because uh now there's a
potential check for my opponent
so what did all my overpressing get me
literally nothing it got me a worse
position than if i had just traded
queens in the first place
so that's the thing i wanted to uh let
you guys know
while it can be very very tempting to
overpress you should really just be
taking your chances where you find them
creating as many tricky positions as
possible but you definitely don't want
to be sacrificing
your position for those chances
that being said i the great news for me
is that my opponent is still 10 years
old he did not
have a birthday during the game and that
means
he's probably not going to be very good
at end games it's just how kids are
i don't know what it is they just don't
understand end games so
still decent chances my opponent plays
king f1 which is strange because
rookie 8 check definitely should have
been played it drives my king away from
the center of the board
now that my opponent didn't play it i
continued with king f8
now we see rookie 5 and i pushed the
pawn out to c4 which is still a little
bit risky
but i thought the position was still
fine we get knight b4
rook d6 and now after king e2
i push the rook away my opponent picks
the b5 square
and we end up in some kind of balance
here uh all my pawns are defended
this knight is actually a little bit
stuck
but neither of us can really make any
progress
without risking a lot so i played the
obvious moves i just brought my king
into the game
my opponent played f4 to take control of
these squares
continued bringing my king in and my
opponent played king
to d2 so
now how can we create some chances for
black where could we possibly possibly
break through
in this game what do we think chat room
as i you're asking did i see this queen
b5 quincy c4 idea over the board
or an analysis i actually did see it
over the board
but my opponent moved reasonably quickly
so i didn't
fortunately i didn't have too much time
to panic about it
fortunately i didn't have too much time
to panic
king zlatan says how did you win this
that's my question for you
how did i win this can you come up with
a winning plan here
so it's a little bit unfair to be
presenting this in a lecture because in
reality i calculated
for 20 plus minutes here before deciding
on my move
and that's about how much time you
should spend if you're gonna play the
move that i played
so what i did is in fact mr monsters
move
c3 and i actually calculated a very long
line
that that actually happens in the game
so the idea of this move is basically
i am sacrificing a pawn more or less in
order to bring the king away from the
center
and start going after the king's side
that was the only idea
i could see in the game to try and win
and so that's what i went for
i decided it didn't look too too risky
and uh it ended up working out so let's
see
the specifics we get b take c3 knight c4
check king d3
i repeated moves once and then took on
a3
and so this is my idea i'm going to take
a3 then after rook a5
i'm going to take c3 and i
am in fact losing this a4 pawn but in
return
i get to play this check my opponent is
coming to b2 now to stop
ideas like a3 and i get my knight over
here
so what's the point well the helpful
arrows on your screen will
hopefully show you the point uh the
point is i gave my opponent
this c pawn but in return i drew this
rook off the fifth rank
allowing my king access to the king side
and i have ideas
such as knight f1 as well to fork these
pawns on the king's side
and in my perfect world i'm gonna win
all the pawns on the king's side before
my opponent can queen the c pawn
and then i will potentially sacrifice
for the c pawn
and win the game ambitious i know
but that's what we went for so in the
game
i realized this knight is actually doing
a nice job of keeping c4
from happening in the immediate future
so i decided to bring my king in
also preventing ideas like rook a6 ideas
like rook a5
my opponent plays knight d3 which i
think is already sort of strange
i thought my opponent was going to play
something like h3
try his best to keep my king out and
maybe even go after my own pawns uh in
the meantime and i think this would have
been a great way to kind of kill the
game
but at this point i think my opponent
saw his past pawn and perhaps got a
little bit excited
and wanted to try to win so opponent
played knight d3
i played knight f1 attacking two things
at the same time
we get rook a3 knight h2 and now c4 so
this was the point of rick a3 it also
helps defend the pawn on g3
i play knight f1 again you know i want
more pawns
upon it plays c5 rook c6 rook c3 uh
and of course because my opponent's 10
years old he calculates everything
correctly
so knight takes g3 the idea was knight
b4 and it's nothing more than a draw
there i have to retreat
i lose my knight white loses all the
pawns
and we can go home so because i'm still
trying to win i played rook c8
stepping out of this threat and now if
my opponent was happy with the draw i
think he would have played this move
night before
allowing me to take take take and take
but i think unfortunately i succeeded
in making my opponent think he had good
chances to win the game so
my opponent tried to keep his c pawn
played this move c6
giving me this g3 pawn but now after c7
it's really only black that can win i
simply bring this knight back into the
game
rook c2 and now i play knight d6
and white now actually only has one move
to
keep the balance every other move is
just dead
lost for white but there's one idea
to hold the draw so you can pause the
video if you want to find it
i haven't i still don't fully understand
all the details on how it works um
it's just kind of an engine line that
draws so
if you want to try to find that go ahead
if not the move of course is rook c5
check
the idea being that after king e4 we get
knight b4
if i take this guy you get knight d5
check
and somehow someway
white is just in time to draw the game
with the idea of
winning uh my piece here and then
bringing the knight back
successfully magically sacrificing for
the pawns and drawn so still
not easy by any means for white but that
was the only idea
instead white played knight b4 now i
simply go knight e8
and white doesn't ever have time to do
anything
uh because white's gonna have to defend
the c pawn the whole time
knight a6 king f4 and the rest is very
easy
the pawn goes up the board in the game
ends
check check i took the pawn on c7 and
white resigned so i think this might
have been the hardest game of the
tournament for me
just because it lasted forever it's 66
moves long
and already it was only in round two
that being said
we've only got about 13 minutes left so
i'm gonna skip ahead in the tournament
we're gonna skip
rounds three and four maybe those will
show up in a later lecture maybe not
but i want to take you now to round five
against
uh the terrifying sergey muratav
so fun fact about sergey um he played
the first round i took a half point by
in the first
round and in round
six of the tournament my fifth game but
it was round six
this guy had five and a half points he
won his first five games just outright
drew his uh no i'm sorry drew
won his first four games outright drew
his fifth game and then he had me
in round six uh so terrifying guy right
so i'm a little bit afraid
uh so i play d4 my normal stuff i did
some research before
turns out this guy is always playing
like these weird half benoni systems
where you go knight f6 c5 and d6
fiance the bishop but then wait to play
e6 until later
um and so imagine my surprise when he
plays 1d5
whatever that's fine that's why i don't
put too much emphasis
on prepping for your opponent beforehand
a lot of the times you just get
surprised anyways so
d5 we just play normal stuff c4 e6
knight c3 and sergey comes out
with the triangle by the way sergey is
an fm fm sergey muritov by the way no
joke
um so he plays the triangle and i'm like
okay you know i've done some work on
this line
i play the marshall gambit my opponent
decides to accept we get take take check
bishop d2 queen takes d4 this is all
just theory
the idea of this line is that white
sacrifices this d4
pawn for a little bit of development and
black gives up this bishop
for this knight on e4 bringing the queen
into the game
now the main move is bishop e2 but i
chose to play knight e2 instead
my opponent quickly played knight a6 and
i played the best move of all time
this is why i play this opening line
just because this move is so cool
uh of course that move is bishop f8
attacking the g7 pawn what are you gonna
do about it
um the point being of course king takes
that f8
is met with checkmate so bishop
is untouchable my opponent plays the
best move
knight e5 but i noticed that he actually
spent a few minutes thinking about
knight e5 before he played it which i or
97
before he played it which i found to be
very very strange because it's
you know it's technically not the only
move but it's kind of the only move
in the position so why is my opponent
thinking here
and then i took on g7 he quickly played
rook g8
i played bishop f6 very very quickly and
again we have another victim of the not
thinking in the opening trap just
because it's the opening
doesn't mean you can't play too quickly
and to his credit my opponent did spend
some time here i think he took about
five minutes on this move after bishop
f6
and then he played a move that blunders
so what is white's threat here
what is white's threat
and justin is asking um
i guess in the past what time the
tuesday lectures are
so justin when you catch up to me here
uh 6 30 p.m central time every tuesday
same time same place
king's laton says this line is a draw
there's some crazy knight before stuff i
think there's a way to play on
uh for both sides in the draw line but
the main line is a draw yes so
of course the threat i'm making that my
opponent missed is to play queen d6
and after e5 the game actually ended
queen d6
is checkmate and two and the the big bad
what i thought was going to be boss of
the tournament um sergey maritov
who had four and a half out of five
hadn't lost a game
beat his first four opponents soundly um
hung checkmate on move uh move 11. so
uh crazy stuff there definitely didn't
expect it this was i think literally the
easiest game of my life
uh in over-the-board chess
and uh yeah you know what just goes to
show sometimes
it's nice to be lucky so
what should he have done instead well of
course against this line there are a few
things you can do i think simplest is
just to go rook g6
when we're going to transpose to one of
the main lines white has to go queen d4
we trade the queens we get c5 bishop c3
knight b4 and the position is more or
less equal here uh but opponent played
e5
and that was the end of the game so uh
lucky for me
got a uh quick win in the morning
and then that set me up to do well in
the final round
the puzzler asks how's an fm below 2300
uscf i don't think he has played
very many uscf tournaments at all i
think he's around 2200 something feeding
as well so i think they might have taken
the feed a rating at some tournament
and went from there but very quickly i
want to speed through
the last round of the tournament this is
the one that secured clear first place
for me
going into this round i was a half point
ahead of the field
there were three people trying to catch
me i was playing one of them
named max zinski and the other two
players were playing
on the board lower than me so
i kind of did some prep for max i looked
at what he played in the past
he has a prettypublicchest.com profile
so i looked on there
tried to prep against him but uh he
ended up surprising me
so again goes to show you how useful
prep is
i also get the feeling that sergey
muritov might have tried to prep
against me maybe he found some games
something i had shown
in this uh martial gambit line and
thought he could trick me there
but in my experience if you prep
something you don't normally play
just doesn't really work out for you
didn't work out for sergey
didn't really work out for evan and
we'll see it doesn't really work out for
max here either
so max plays e4 c6 knight c3
d5 knight f3 and we get a two nights
caro
now i knew that max played this and i
was expecting this i played my normal
line with knight f6
i've been considering switching from
this line because there are some dubious
ideas where white might be able to get
an advantage
but i felt the most comfortable so i
stuck with what i knew taking my own
advice
we get e5 knight e4 and now my opponent
surprises me
with knight takes e4 this has been
played 17 times in the lead chess
database
as opposed to the other ideas which have
been played hundreds of times so knight
takes e4
was the big surprise max had in his prep
for me
so i took back we get knight g5
i go queen d5 and this is why
this move is sort of rare you are just
losing this pawn on e5
nothing you can really do about it but
my opponent had planned for this
and played d4 and we see now the point
of white's play
is to sacrifice a pawn so
here we are my opponent has three pieces
developed i have zero pieces developed
uh how should we try to continue the
game
i had no experience in this position had
never seen before in my life
going into this game so this one was
definitely a bit nerve-wracking it's the
final round
likely all i need is a draw to at least
will definitely at least tie for first
with a draw or maybe even get clear
first
and my opponent is you know playing this
garbage sacrificing all his center pawns
and trying to checkmate me
so how do we do it what are our
priorities here
as the black player
merrick says compensation yeah
definitely white has a ton of
compensation here
no arguing that why not queen takes b2
yeah you guys are psycho
okay literally insane
did you hear me you you are winning the
chicago open u-2300 section
all you need is a draw to get out of
this place
uh with you know the first place title
and check
by the way and you guys want to move the
queen again and play queen takes b2
just i can't believe it um so this is
actually
uh a bit too much for black here you you
can't play this move as well
white's just going to castle you now
have to extract your queen again
and you are losing a little bit too much
time so queen takes b2 isn't going to do
it
of course your only priority here as
black is to find a way
to develop your pieces castle your king
and survive the opening
so it turns out the most popular move
here is h6 for good reason as we'll see
later
but in the game i chose just to develop
instead with knight d7
uh i don't think my opponent had seen
this move before
in his prep so already we're back on
level footing my opponent is out of his
prep
and so am i so he comes up with queen e2
uh i play knight f6 this was the idea
just bringing the pieces into the game
and now my opponent hits me with f4 and
this is when i start kind of regretting
not kicking this knight away so of
course what's my opponent's idea
well he wants to break things open on
the e file
with f5 i wasn't quite sure
the best way to continue here it turns
out in this case
maybe you can take on b2 but i chose the
simpler queen a5 check
bishop d2 and queen c5 trying to keep my
king
or my opponent's king from castling on
the king's side also trying to keep an
eye on this
f5 square threatening to find a way to
develop
again now that i've taken all the center
pawns i'm up a clean pawn
my goal is not to threaten you know too
much material
my goal is just to get the pieces into
the game and complete development so i
go queen c5
and my opponent plays bishop c4 i get i
have to go e6
and now i realize i'm in a little bit of
trouble here uh because i didn't kick
this knight away earlier on in the
opening
my opponent's attacking ideas become
very very strong against this e6 pawn
here f5 is going to be difficult to stop
and uh things could go badly that being
said black definitely isn't out of it
yet
um i do have this extra pawn and that's
sort of my saving grace here so
white castle's queen side i develop with
bishop e7
and we get a very strange move by white
uh a3
so this gives away pretty much i think
all of the advantage
for white here a3 is one of those moves
that
kind of has an idea like my opponent's
idea is to play
bishop b4 at some moment but it's just
way too slow and kind of besides the
point in this position
i was worried more about moves like rook
f1 preparing f5
f5 directly rook e1
g4 for example any move that advances
the plan against the e pawn
is really what my opponent should have
been playing for uh rather than this
sort of irrelevant
relevant move a3 when you sacrifice a
pawn especially center pawn you need to
play actively and quickly and my
opponent didn't do that
instead played with a3 and because of
that i was able to consolidate a lot
with this move knight d5
uh my opponent sensed that the attack
was fading so he played f5
but now i get to simplify it with bishop
takes g5 takes
and castle so i've castled haven't even
lost my extra pawn
and as such i think uh black doesn't
have too much to be worried about here
uh white captures on d5 i capture back
uh threatening this guy
and it turns out my opponent does have
sort of one last idea
to keep the dynamic balance in the game
with this move bishop e7
i was planning rook e8 but after rookie
one i do have to move the queen
queen c4 for example and my opponent's
gonna step out of it
keep the queens on the board and the
game's going to stay interesting
instead though my opponent tried f6 and
now from here i managed to take over the
game
bishop f5 comes out of course i'm not
interested in
playing g6 or taking on f6 this is going
to make my king a little bit
unnecessarily weak
simply bishop f5 and if my opponent ever
plays fg7
i'm happy to step to the e file and
temporarily use this pawn to help defend
my king
so bishop f5 was played in the game my
opponent came up with rook h to e1
but unfortunately this allows black to
sort of take the advantage
so black to move here and seize
the initiative we've been playing
defensively for so long
it's finally time to start going on the
attack
what can we do
all right and i'm noticing now that i'm
running a bit out of time so if you do
want to find it for yourself
go ahead and pause the video but i'm
just going to show my idea there are a
lot of different moves you can play here
you can try and get on the e file
with rook a8 note that queen e8 is met
with queen c2 mate
not recapturing but i chose d4 in the
game and i think this is a pretty nice
idea
to press the position the thread is
going to be d3 now
by the way we're also threatening bishop
takes c2 and this bishop on g5
and all of the weak spots in white's
position start to kind of come under
fire at once here
my opponent tried f takes g7 but now i
can simply step to e8
i'm no longer back rank mated because my
opponent captured on g7
we get takes takes takes and takes
my opponent plays rook d2 and
unfortunately for me
the game isn't over um black definitely
has a pretty sizable advantage here
but there's not any really a knockout
blow you would think bishop c2 would be
working
but it turns out there's this annoying
bishop e7 even bishop f8 check idea
uh to follow and so there's no knockout
punch here
um and since we're running out of time
i'm gonna kind of zoom through the rest
of the game
it lasted forever but the last point i
want to make on a practical note
is that my opponent prepped for me
played a line he wasn't comfortable with
and now has a slightly worse position
but worse than all of that
is he has two minutes on the clock and
that's the worst thing that you can do
in your tournament games if you play
something you're not comfortable with
you're going to go down on time
and then when you really need the time
you're not going to be able to have it
so my opponent to his credit held on for
a long time
we pushed the game for a long long time
pawns came off the board
eventually though
eventually we get this position my
opponent plays bishop a7
sensing that h3h2 is coming and i
come up with a nice tactic here although
i'm also starting to run out of time
we start with queen e5 my opponent plays
rook h1
knowing that the threat is h3h2 and here
black actually has a winning move in the
game for whatever reason
i saw the tactic on the following move
um
i actually calculated this ahead of time
i saw it on the uh on the next move
but didn't realize i could play it here
so of course
black to move the winning idea is we get
to snap off this c2 pawn very thematic
with the rooks disconnected to look for
checks that
fork the king and the rook now in my
head
i only saw check and check to fork the
king in the rook
so i wasted the tempo let my opponent
take and then took on c2 so now of
course if takes i go check
check and pick up the rook um the game
continued though
now with bishop d4 i attack the rook we
get rook h1
uh queen d5 now attacks these pieces
we get check bishop back to g6 and
bishop e3
and now the game once again is going to
continue for a long time
but my opponent at this point is playing
on the increment and
things get a little dicey for my king
but at the end of the day
i managed to push these pawns on the
queen side pick up this b
pawn and at this point bla white is
entirely busted
bring the king up and
finally here in the time pressure uh my
opponent blunders so at this point
white is already dead lost king f3 is a
devastating threat my opponent tried
bishop f4 but i simply capture
and i actually got checkmate on the
board
thus ending my run at the 2021
chicago open so as i speak varakobian is
in the room with me here he's going to
get set up and he's going to be directly
following this
lecture with another excellent lecture
hopefully you guys enjoyed my games from
the chicago open
found something in it to be instructive
um i had a lot of fun
obviously at the tournament and i hope i
can share
more successful tournaments with you
guys in the future let me know what you
think in the comments
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
i will see you next time
you